pajamas for puppies and weird al'
approved accordion hero I look like this
because it's episode 3 of IMG well not
so fast caution wet fool Batman last
week we saw the world's smallest living
frog
well this week visualize us showed us
the world record holder for the smallest
handmade teddy bear and one possible use
for it and on Kotaku mr. snuffles showed
us his concept for the rated M version
of kinectimals and gif bring some are
weird some are surprising and some are
baby who dokkan but the two that are the
hottest on dig right now involved what I
do on all of my first dates and the
lyrics to never gonna give you up which
will surprise people who think it's a
still image by morphing into the
ultimate gift roll so do your friends a
favor and send them this image using the
link in this video's description you can
also find links to every image I discuss
in the description and you know what
what the H here's another gift and it's
not even new but it was actually new to
me this week it's an optical illusion
that starts with a black and white
picture of a castle but if you stare at
the middle black dot keep staring good
keep staring don't move okay
you're doing a great job and back to the
black-and-white picture there's color
I'm not messing with you look at a
different part of the picture besides
the middle and the color will disappear
but as soon as your eyes move back to
the center dot the color reappears
[Music]
listicles pointed me to manifest 25
horrifying meat products whether it's
hand shredded ask me to Alex's meat or
just plain British my favorite were the
red hot balls which is a great
transition to red hot flesh super
tremendous calm brought us 13 hilarious
sunburns some word emasculating some
were even more D masculine some were had
burned but they all proved that no
matter how bad you've been pranked
there's always room to photobomb pot on
BuzzFeed Taylor Lautner looks like
manbearpig and these Turtles look like
emoticons
[Music]
via Boeing Boeing an artist doing some
science and of course by science I mean
whiskey and by making whiskey what I
really mean is fermenting the sugar a
year and of all diabetic people mmm
five shots please and what do you know
some friends of mine started a tumblr
collecting bad Justin puns the gram
Bieber Saturday night Bieber and of
course golden retriever the list goes on
and on every day and part of the reason
it goes on is people like you I love all
of your submissions over at facebook.com
slash Vsauce gaining my favorite from
this week came from Lucas and it really
puts lag into perspective so what are
you waiting for go over there right now
and show me the best images you found
this week be sure to subscribe to vsauce
for more and hey guys thanks for
watching
[Music]